you
[Music]
okay so so this is our three principles
of data science which kind of it's a
it's kind of a summarization what I mean
tried to do as a data scientist it is in
over the last ten years so let me share
my view of data science of pretty much
is a burkha view of data science we
think data science the reemerging of
computational stitches you're thinking
in the context of domain problems it's
very much reflected in our curriculum
you have these three components computer
side medicine stats and domain knowledge
and they design some people's
intersection other says Union but I do
you think as a team you should have also
recovered and the claiming of Siri
merging is because this little story a
big story like statistics in herman
heroin with suspicion in the US Census
Bureau 1890 it was predicted that the US
sensor would take 13 years and will be
too long because every 10 years so he
was charged to speed up the computation
as a result he invented Holloway's
tabulating machine which is I had the
company with one of the fall company
that form IBM so there was really a good
example that statistic job computation
and now we kind of back again it's like
my Berkeley called Simon's Institute I
was talking to them tonight you cannot
imagine computing without data and data
without computing these teachers have to
couple and of course the domain
meanwhile the mode and founder
substitutes the artificial was very much
driven by situation antics to a certain
extent the evolution theory of Darwin
and also gotten and also carp use and
was very much tried to give a
mathematical foundation for Darwin's
evolution theory and we're kind of
coming back together the stare and I'm
now in the sense that statistics will
also kind of work with science from the
interpretability mechanics explanations
of things try to bring stitches into
science and I'm always country coming
through a very successful period of
prediction also facing the same problem
in terminology and you use general data
protection regulation last year really
gives the right to explanation and
demands this algorithm to be human
interval
and cross-validation is be really
helpful to avoid overfitting in certain
most of cases so not all but it really
doesn't really dress explanation problem
and I have been kind of tried to bring
stability as a unified framework to
bring many things together to address
reproducibility and interview bility and
well and abuse on the stability of
knowledge
it's like self-evident I was a principal
that knowledge is stable and somebody
actually gave me a code recently can't
go back to Plato in his dialogue man oh
speaking that opinions don't have to be
tied down but knowledge has to be tied
down this has to be stable so it's very
common-sense thing we shall have and
actually if you look at central limit
theorem which is it's really a stability
visa if you look at the swapping Lynda
breaks parking trick that's not how I
learned central limit theorem badly
Karen Starr has a nice seven different
ways of proving central main theorem and
the modern a lot a random matrix result
actually through a perturbation
technique to prove limiting result so
it's really fundamental sure article two
and jackknife which is delete one and we
mention earning people call iris meet
stability and has been a lot of result
connecting with generalization error
model selection the su clustering causal
inference and differential privacy or
have this stability kind of our say
angle to it or can be interpreted
through the framework so I kind of try
to put together called that stability
principle as a minimum requirement for
scientific reducibility and
interoperability so when you apply this
stability principle you need to the user
specify what are the appropriate
perturbations so you have to take the
contacts into account to prove it's a
proper way so that's a very heavy-duty
word is your data or models and you
define stability measure so for
prediction actually a used car
validation is pretty stable and deep
learning the same way but deep learning
you cannot interpret the parameters
right just too and still is very
redundant so you would you find that on
your disk are
the stability an example data
perturbation in the ID case
cross-validation I mentioned bootstraps
up something you can add amount of data
the o Brahmin did to data and you can
feed them all to take the residual and
then do the perturbation the one form I
think is testing confirms that here's a
machine learning yet it's actually which
already incorporate also model-based
mechanistic model based simulations as a
form of data perturbation actually Peter
abuse group at Berkeley they actually do
this robotic arm reaching to an object
it's a lot of for human to do that in
record so what they did they I did data
which is simulated from PDE models for
the arm reaching and really help the
result so so so this is trying to build
a platform include the traditional ones
but also for us to entertain once which
hasn't been endowed ways and model
probation so this the paper actually
stability was my two key lecture for
Bernoulli society like four years ago
so as trying very very hard to connect
sample stability ways to tease robust
statistics and I realized that we now
have so many different models right
robust it is a saying I want to measured
which work at the post models like
laplacian and Gaussian and some
different merchants models like I leave
a big part which is just very vaguely
defined say only second moment or some
smoothness so it's kind of stability yes
and then actually the model is not very
stable
exactly okay I have a kind of a project
with suppose I'd Berkeley Shan Shan Shan
do candy yeah we have been talking about
that my conjecture he also grades that
actually we don't have stability there
yeah so I'm actually want to work with
him to prove that that it doesn't so
that's where it's almost impossible to
do the traditional statistics yeah
exactly
so he's we're talking when we have been
meeting yeah so exactly I agree with you
yeah so that's not a regime we do a lot
of statistics our I can imagine that
maybe there's certain particular
projection with something might be
doable I don't know but in general it's
probably like it's the same thing as a
our model when you have the coefficient
at a unit circle you already have that
yeah it's a much simpler model than
stochastic and that's this is your
physics model and in regression simple
we often face to do lassoo to do rich
right I was talking to Rahu about it and
for me I also to non-negative matrix
factorization for genomic project there
we have a non-convex problem and you
have multiple modes for me I feel each
mode is a well-defined model when you
have multiple modes you really have
class of models I want my whatever
answer to be kind of resistant or robust
to which local minimum you end up with
so we actually use that idea to have a
way to select number of component angry
major factorization which works very
well and now I'll show you that our 20
models based on three version deep
learning LSU and they all give similar
prediction result so what I seek is
really about only one of the theories
that which are supported by alternative
models just to be on the conservative
side and you have just people up to
sensitivity analysis in Bayesian
modeling so there's a lot of
consideration I see this form of model
perturbation so here what I see in my
group have been doing is kind of take
mushroom learning as how I teach these
days to you might teach a statistic cost
I use prediction are to visualization
and that
production as a first kind of benchmark
to assess goodness-of-fit and their lack
of good prediction models I kind of go
back to most ability and inference
instead of start with p-values and order
and predictions is very very easy to
explain to beginners and I think you
don't need a lot of the iodine is you
just need some aspect of things to be
stable cross-training where it's a
testing so just much and you can do
fuzzy logic prediction you don't have to
have stochastic model either you can
have your gut feeling that's what
traders do right so it's a measure don't
have to have a generative nature and
computational address too much here but
later they will analyze some stochastic
gradient algorithm and relate to
stability so that's most of the big data
we do one version the other gradient
method so I'm sure for the rest of talk
to project from neuroscience the first
is like data perturbation to see to
bring better our see better smoothing
parameter selection lassoo pressure than
cross-validation by use cross-validation
and the second is ongoing project try to
really do transfer learning and to
neuroscience and the guiding principle
for my group is really we like to solve
scientific problems and to really really
care for validation of the method before
we generalize to other problems and my
students embedded in the Bell Labs they
spend substantial amount of time so we
try to play a bit of the scientists I
mean John Tukey said that statistics in
complaining everybody's backyard and
I've tried to go a bit in the front yard
with them because a lot of the new data
are collected in a way that didn't it's
technology moves so fast it's not like
you made a lot more knowledge about
understand technology so it's good it's
a good opportunity for us to do it with
them and a lot of understanding for data
processing from other areas actually
helped them
the position to make sure that everyone
is doing statistics of machine learning
I know but the things we don't go for
number of papers and and not you know
actually about more than half of my
student go to industry so that's I think
the Academy America hopefully will
change a bit we look at more substance
than look at number of papers because I
think we cannot really evaluate all the
papers anymore
so this a project scan the old from 2011
and its collaboration mr. jackal ants
live we have been working together for
the last ten years I took a man year off
and stayed in his lab for a year 2:06
and shinji now back in Japan and you
walk back to Israel so these are the
main people some of you might have seen
it was all over the news like five years
ago so the data is such that three human
subject line down under fMRI machine and
MMR signals were measured in different
visual areas and each voxel
in the fmi domain is actually hundreds
and salmon's in neurons so it's not
direct neural measurement is indirect
and the person was we're watching creeps
of movies from YouTube and also movie
trailers how do I play it I don't see my
cursor
oh I don't see oh I see it there I don't
see it on my screen here you go
so on the left hand side is the movie
the input to the brain and this is a
measurement after processing you know
just a lot of processing done the red
means intensive response blue means I'm
not so interested so I actually use this
in myelitis own data science speech to
show that humans have very short
attention span we get bored very quickly
therefore we need new names because the
CSP have been really good with new names
since the teaching which is key with
statistics right it has to evolve over
over a hundred years and we did so many
different things only we understand
everything which is two senses obeys for
statistics so that's why I was using
this to show that we need new names
otherwise people get confused we get
bored we're not very patient that is
predictive coding right after we can
predict what's going on we just give up
and we don't have to waste the energy to
figure out what's going on okay so
here's the result so Jack was all over I
mean I think MPI had the coverage
economists at the coverage everybody had
the coverage on this work and even the
Chinese some I read in China had the
coverage on this I even got a few calls
but I got Jack to do the work and my
student got interviewed on is really
television and his grandfather was
clearly pleased so so this is what
people was surprised to see and for me I
want to come back to this this is
basically have two steps
why is fall we're modeling right the key
step is cabal features a 3d cabal future
which peels out years and you're
assigned computer design a fter that is
simple is some like la soupe method okay
but the feature makes that work that was
huge amount of work
and then that's the forward model so for
each Bacchus we had that is forward
model and the reconstruction actually
was very simple so what do we did that
went with the new data the
reconstructing data ephemera was ten
replicates it was a lot higher - nice -
signal-to-noise ratio so we just
projected all the one minion movie clips
into the FMR space and find the 100
closest to observed and then we did the
average okay so actually the posterior
you're basically treating the database
of a million clips as like empirical
prior and well yet 26,000 dimension
after all the processing for the
regression and actually was not enough
that's why all the blurring so actually
I'm thinking about going back and to do
a more money for everything to get
sharper result but there that's what's
it that so the posterior probability is
exactly what we did actually the case
very very slowly but magically the
ordering still has information so if you
take a random hundred you won't get
result so you take the top 100 you
gather yourself but we don't really
understand but the numbers are not that
different so it's a mystery we don't
quite understand so that's what it's
like an engineering success so I want to
take this project and say that I want to
do some neuroscience can answer the
question were in the image a particular
walk so is the intricity right this is
saying that and this is three boxes so
each gabbar actually is relate to a
location that's what you see so these
are the locations like abroad removing
the frequency and and also the
orientation and also the time so I'm
only plotting the location so you see
that series like models that seem to
suggest that this box or a is
interesting all over the place and
neuroscience scientifically doesn't make
a lot of sense because we're pretty
localized so we develop something called
es CV adding stability through
cross-validation which really shrunk
advanced you mine I'll be right right
but it's a lot more ease
so this is more suggestive Oh if you
want to do fall I've spent yes yes so we
haven't we look at each individual boxes
in theory we can actually test this
right we can just start putting things
to here and different future and see
whether this works or like that well we
haven't gotten I mean there's lots of
correlations right between the features
right that's what got picked up yeah and
if you look at the prediction with say
yeah a severe mother actually we don't
lose much prediction I know that was a
surprise I was willing for a concise
model and lose some prediction accuracy
for this data because so much
correlation actually we load lost like
one point three percent over these
thousands of voxels but the size of the
model reduced by 60 percent
so what we did was exactly I'll call
that the PS workflow we use prediction
the cross-validation selection as the
lambda so let's just take each lambda I
look at another stability measure look
at all the projected coefficients to the
predictors and look at how much they
vary from the grand average if say you
do ten for the validation you compare
with the size and this is really
actually a test statistic you basic look
and it's the how many times you did the
cross-validation right because evidence
to cross-validation usually follows who
so we're not adding computation
complexity which is building on top of
that obeys is the yeah yes yes beta is
the coefficient minus so I should have
no relation that I don't have and this
is you can interpret it as testing
whether X beta being 0 it's a test
statistic so what we do is that we use
as I said I use
the cross-validation selection as a
goodness-of-fit and then I shrink the
model to a smaller one and to this
stability is the best locally and that's
the choice okay so because if I have
beta as constants very stable had
nothing to do with my data
so this cross-validation choice forced
me to fit real data and works so that's
where we have this yes see we have been
using this for other projects which tend
to not always give you the same
prediction error but because by
definitions or smaller models always
give you a more concise model it's just
easier to look at so we tried it with
some more nonlinear random forest space
a model there we can find stable high
level interactions but you lose there's
something just noise you can do
prediction you cannot pin them down
so there you lose prediction performance
by like ten percent or something here we
barely lost anything so this is like
theta perturbation try to go for
stability and the next projects also
going for predictive and stable
Association for interval T and then
hopefully we can guide intervention
experiments for Neuroscience so this is
a gam project is led by my group three
people and with Jack's lab and then
collect the data ten years ago it took
two years so this is different data
single neuron data is behaving macaca
and mike is the current student so
recent year students that student and
that student Network so Google know this
is single neuron data and not human
either so for the ever mine we only use
actually v1 v2 so we have two major
pathways for information in visual
processing one is what minds what we're
so this is a word pathway we try to
decide what we're looking at and we when
we to a use for reconstruction because
we don't have a good forward model for
reform so we for it's very difficult
area before IT which is object
recognition so it's more sophisticated
than edge detection but it's not
sophisticated enough to have the whole
object so people have done very
controlled stimuli
with geometric curvature texture so very
synthetic stimuli to have some
conjectures and we're going to use
natural stimuli and on the other hand
you have all these deep learning stuff
and we didn't start with steep learning
usually I try to stay in code areas but
I have been joined to the hot area I'll
tell you why
so this is kind of French AI and I'm in
the camera I think humans at least a
good humans can still do a lot more than
currency ends and I think in my lifetime
I'm safe that the machines won't take
over I feel very happy about that and I
think that's the challenge for AI it's
actually how do you reproduce intuition
and conscious spring which is now
defined actually human intelligence is
not well defined either so that's the
circular argument but I do think that
the future will be a human machine and
collaboration that we already kind of
doing it so for this project we try to
answer actually we started from this
what do we power neurons to and then we
are now having to touch upon this
question how much do convolution
networks resemble brain function and
actually to my surprise I have to say
that we do learn some evidence it does
capture something so what happened was
that we had this project since 2013 with
Julie Mayer oh you were by Germany to
analyze that data and we build our own
two layer Network use sparse coding very
simple but worked state-of-the-art for
that data said Internet prediction what
do I mean by stated bars I will use v1
as a benchmark how well can do
prediction what we won and we compare
for before that's how we compare why
it's a good result and DeCarlo stupid em
and she actually has a parallel line and
they did a lot of the prediction work
and published and we had this work
presented paper still being written
because jack has a fun time and ma
protested that you know has been for
years and he said the papers that you
know took six years so the price to pay
to work with the top neuroscience lab
and I gave a talk at the Jerry semester
meeting two years ago and Joshua Benji
was talking deep net and now fella I was
making my own nets so the questions if
we just use the net trained by image net
would will happen so that's why I got
into deep learning to my surprise I had
my two best people on this project so
I'm very I know the result would be very
hard to improve but the deep Nets
improved a tiny bit so that's how I
jumped in and the Carlos group had a
little bit different image they don't
have complete net you mean they have
this is semi natural images with object
imposed on top of natural image and they
in some somewhere pushing so hard on
interpretations because it kind of had
predicted result but it's good we
replicate their prediction actually it's
not a bad thing that we did it
independently but we're now pushing very
hard on the interpretation so the data
was 70 neurons from tumour cakes and we
didn't find any difference we put them
together its eyes well isolated we fall
neurons they've used this typical
complex stimuli to find where are the v4
neurons of course it can be wrong but
that's what they call we found Euron's
and black-and-white images and we did
transfer learning in three senses I
explained and gained state-of-the-art
prediction performance for neurons and
then we have been spending two years try
to get stable interpretations of our
predictive models so that we think that
we can characterize the neurons so this
is an image net Alex net and is trained
down color images and for classification
tag is human labels so it's transfer
learning the sense that we have black
and five minutes and nothing to do with
the we just use this as black bug assets
after people feed the image now we take
it as the processing box
we got the features and it's very simple
the sewer regression and free to be
found you're wrong
so this is task very high-level visual
tasks this is a single neuron and this
is human data this is my cake this is a
color this is black and white we did
didn't do anything we took it and just
changed the black and white image just
three channels for the same stigma
a middle color right so we didn't do any
alteration and we did rich
hola sue we got very good researcher
than slightly better than our self-made
model so this is already a human-machine
collaboration with other labels Imogen
you know Alex ain't gonna work so well
so a lot of our see crowdsource human
intelligence wanting to image like Alex
not in the image name they belong now I
have other nights right well vgg we have
Google net and we have these two
regression masters so we suddenly have
six models right I said this is about
model perturbation and we want to see
how they work into a prediction and
visualization and we're going to
interpret only the part that six later
we got twenty models we look at the
higher layers give similar results so
this is the over Oprah prediction
performance so Gabor you can see
definitely doesn't work for
before-and-after layer two you have many
good there's give similar performance so
I'm gonna consider two and then I will
go for other layers mention so this is
the soup with three different nets they
basically give similar reason the
correlation cross the different models
is like 0.92 and this is the data so
it's indistinguishable and on average
rich gives the best prediction
performance by it's pretty big point for
new number parameters and the zoo shrink
to about four hundred one thing is that
for high signal noise you usually
correct the tsuba so as we remove bias
but for this data there's still noise to
be removed you to reach this become like
elastic net so this is pretty noisy data
so OS actually hurts usually for higher
signal ratio it correct for the bias but
for this data you want more
regularization that suit doesn't give me
now recognization so now we do the
interpretation so this is particularly
wrong we want to see that this basically
is a radar from the models too
indicate that where does this new run
care about its kind of tune your region
and you can see that for the sewerage
even the suits a little quite a bit
worse point one worse take you very
similar sound so we're happy to hear to
see that oh this is probably where this
neuron care about this is like
suggestive which is hard to interpret
that this neuron care spot there are
better ones and then cross three
different nets they also be very stable
results so now we just say that that's
something we trust and we end up using
evocative many furtive dream to
characterize the neurons so what Steve
dream is that you have a fitted model
right so one dimensional function with a
high dimensional input space and you
take a random starting point and then
you just find the local minimum and
that's the image usual so there's a lot
of consistency with random starting
point I will show you a movie and this
is the inhibitory patterns that's where
the neuron gets negative results here
you can see
that's the iteration from ynoice
converge to something so it's pretty
stable and this is a different way of
looking at from my group Rebecca's work
because super heat it's a way to look at
high dimensional data with a response
so I'm also advertising for that for
data visualization and this is taking
the images in the database we have black
and white find one that excite this
motor neuron saying that and you can see
this it says it's kind of texture by see
regular we can already say what it is
this is another new around which our
favorite one our favorite new neurons
again the SU doesn't quite because a
neuron doesn't really jump so we think
that you reach is biological more
meaningful the region for neuron to care
by UGS very continues and the su has a
problem sometimes sparsity and jump
around so reject is better and this is a
neuron again it's pretty consistent it's
in the middle and this is the pattern
this neuron care about curvature this is
the inhibitory neurons and this is the
movie you can see similarly
for paper you cannot do that so we have
the super heat to show that you know
convergence is pretty stable so you see
that nothing happens here it's because
this is the color filters and we have
black and white image so nothing happens
in that yeah this multiple no that's
what the hope I think for computation
the high dimension will definitely hope
everybody's trying to get a simpler
version so I'll show you some
compression Ares I'll try to go that way
and this is layer three you've seen
already so you can see that Google
magnet actually has this funny features
this is use layer three as processing
layer for the not exactly the same by
the consistent again the consistency is
this curvature Google net Daphne not
something funny there it had this
artificial like I looking things right I
think you have seen other deep dream
images like that from google night too
but that's why we look for consistency
we only say that the things are
consistent we're not going to interpret
this I like thing to go don't see a
tomorrow is same prediction they might
be there but we just don't have evidence
to say and for this neuron I should have
this first for the last neuron you can
see that the image is picked up
maximizing the model neural has a clear
signature of curvature much more clear
than the other one so this is really a
curvature new wrong and there are other
ten neural eight neurons you saw this
one you saw this one this one basic like
we when you run Zacks edge detector it's
known as some of the v1 you we found
your runs like V 1 because if from the
design point of view it's not a good
idea to have same functionality and you
are in the same place if that part of
bring get knocked out you pretty
hopeless but it's good to have
redundancy and also it is possible that
neurons might have plasticity have
multiple roles too so you can see that
they are all kind of different but I
think a characteristic and to also
compare you
you take this we have this
characterization neurons and also I give
you nine images it's possible a neuron
like all of them because there's no
reason why one neuron only likes Y exact
image maybe a group of distribution
neurons excited right so so and but you
see that so now we have 70 by a neuron
each have some characterization of the
favorite pattern and you do the cross
you can see they really prefer its own
model you see the diagonal but this
group is like similar neuron they like
similar things and this group is like
some exact Ori images become the
inhibitory for another group right so
it's all present and to kind of follow
up what Jennifer was saying that we also
try to simplify things to understand so
one project by Risa is actually
compression so we use the reduction of
accuracy this is back to the 1000
category image net to remove filters so
we're not just removing weights we're
moving filters and that's more effective
oh and deep learning to work on small
device and the watch one so we're
compressing more amount to 90 percent
you can see the pattern kind of still
persist okay so there's something two
guys that we can remove lots of them
there's something which just show
another way that there's something real
there is not exact but you see a certain
feature occurring we lose very little
prediction accuracy and if you look more
carefully into the compression result
and you see that a lot of the futures
actually we remove at the color futures
but for a lot of object detection we
don't need the color rights the shape so
you can see that makes sense and we have
another way we submitted something the
nips workshop got accepted was that will
you also use the classification label to
give futures meanings right so if this
filter it's very important
for a classification from particular
label that it's almost saying this is
this futures functionality so we both
use visualization in the input and also
the output to characterize the futures
and we really try to hope to do
experiments oh I see all this work
predictability and stability it's kind
of scientific a recommendation system we
want to recommend things for people to
the experiments so now we're claiming
that the steve dream images image is
characterizing neuron we can actually
test it by feeding it back because
actually that's a problem people don't
know how to probe a neuron they do
synthetic ones right and it's not very
natural and what else do you do this
give you a data-driven way of generating
images to put it back into the loop and
prove it but check is out of his ology
experiment so I need to find another
collaborator to do that with the
computing with the files you can't do a
real-time so that will be really proving
this and the other things we can go back
to this as I said this so this one is
about belief all right so we can go back
to the movie project and then really
improve the reconstruction use the v4
area ephemera which we didn't use
because we didn't have a good forward
before model so these are the two
testable experiments we could do and the
last bit is computability right so you
have Turing machine you have Turing
computability I'm gonna take a very
practical view is that computability
means rates of convergence in each
tradition of divination mastered
although I cannot relate that to right
there then they're not computed by try
but listen I couldn't make it work so
we're looking at a Christmas tree
ability which is delete one and there
have been quite a bit work relating
these two and also this so there's
beginning some work so we add to this
link how to relate convergence rate to a
grecian stability we basically have some
inequality to have the access rate
bounded by stability
arrow plus optimization around using
stability bound and estimation bound we
can actually show that a very stable
algorithm
I'll converse to fast which is
completely reasonable but you actually
prove it yeah more precise and we that
analyze some special greeting Agron
experiences and into and the papers
being written so summary I hope I give
some evidence and stablish
predictability and go to stability is a
good workflow to really do use machine
learning and then bring bad a lot of
statistical considerations and we also
tried it with genomics and text mining
project the stability principles so you
can say vague that this lot of room for
people to improvise to apply to their
problems it's doesn't really dictate
what perturbation you do but just force
you to think was appropriate and that's
actually a huge amount of work to really
make a case and we can end up with
testable characterization neurons for
fall our experiments and there's a lot
of theory I think can be done and I do
think that this is I do feel like CNN
trained in trinda imagenet it's very
early layer to capture something about
prime visual processing and I talked to
some student in Berkeley they have been
try to use we use image net and then for
radiology tasks so they start with image
net and then they do improvements for
the particular task say tumor detection
but it's kind of you have the rough
vision model from this image net and
then you tune for particular tasks the
ones that you have an average human
model as image net and then you tune it
as a radiologist anyway and it's pretty
amazing for visual tasks I think because
it captured something I was surprised
I'm using the last kind of jumping how
the areas but with evidence I did
so here's what I said that Berkeley we
have been working on this for the last
three years so now we want the
intellectual vision which is the
integration of CS and staff for data
science to really have a structure to
support it and the report 105 pages is
on my website and the data
8.now has in the second year serving
1,000 students a semester so 2,000
students
and then I was on the team with two CS
and a staff faculty to design DTS 100
last semesters and now is 250 and David
Connor is the interim dean and we have a
new data sign major inventions and
science being approved and they can be
discussion for that like engineer also
have a version of data science so it's
really quite exciting and a lot of us
there and these are the links at your
sank the NSF Center for technology that
support the neuroscience work thank you
[Applause]
questions yes well I think I've tried to
build the platform to unify definitely I
think but I think the earliest reference
about stability actually say Rachel
regression which is a ticker called
paper 1943 right he was solving an
integral equation and he linearized it
and then he for numerical reasons he did
reach there loop analyzation
so that's it's a regularization so a lot
of times I feel like Bayesian models I
think Purdue has been doing this kind of
form of regularization definitely but
the thing harder for Bayesian models I
have a hard time I you have more than
two layers to know how the
regularization from different era
interact so it's a little black box
there - I think one we doing that but I
don't want to be broader than that so
for example including the mechanistic
models for the arm right it's you can
see the regularization your ways like
you simulate this data from the model
you're kind of pulling the data to all
data base not in the analytical form
anymore it's more like putting to
another Cloud Data better than not
having it
it's now exactly right but pulling in
that direction help you but it's not
really analytical so I hope to be
prouder than than just a I needed
analytical regularization and you can
also like data fusion your way I was
saying that you can also see it's kind
of a form of data participation right so
try to be very broad and then we have a
common kind of language to talk about
this different thing that may be
compared are the questions how much you
have another data comparison analytical
measures can you map them it just seems
very very common sense right that's why
I talked to this philosopher science
colleague recently a math so somebody
must have talked about it right you
philosophy of science and he said yeah
Plato did it's a good it's a good person
to a site and yes my right what you're
doing is basically reconstructing
by looking at it neuron by neuron or
voxel maybach so you're actually
reconstructing the image that is
actually perceived in the brain you hope
yeah that's the new reconstruction I'm
trying to say that I did all this
different things similar something
stable right but the ultimate test is
fitted back to see the neuron get
excited right all my images so that's
the first project right yeah you you
reconstructed that from looking at the
MRI yeah that's the bold signals yeah
look at those signals constructing the
image
yeah that's why Time magazine called the
time my reading but it's not ready yet
but people got quite scared I just felt
like there's so many other thing that
attention we didn't take into account
person that's sleeping yeah me me yeah
would your method actually be able to
reconstruct images of the dream so
people had follow-up studies actually
they make people out and ask them what
did you dream so they did do that but
it's not how much you remember right do
you never know exactly but you can get
quite close but I think the precision
has to be improved you think for human
figures because there are a lot of
YouTube clips if you like to talk to the
camera so that's why we do the best so
if we only concentrate on human talking
to the camera I think we can do a lot
better but yeah
yeah well and also like a blob of animal
or something yeah yeah detector even yes
but nothing we're not there yeah the
precision I think definitely caused a
lot of interest I think of people but I
don't know I mean you know my hand I'm
Merrick here to see go there on the
other hand I'm kind of scared to go
there so I start working on v4 neurons
and Jack's could move down to like a
text audio and image and more like so
nobody seemed to want to really kill
that application I think this the
implications can be quite scary yeah so
we chose but I'm kind of want to improve
the precision by that's why people are
so surprised you can go that far as I
told you after you it's pretty simple of
course a lot of things after you do it
it's pretty simple
but ahead of time was quite surprising
but we saw the web minion movie clips
wouldn't have been possible we kind of
its kind of the prior video experience
like stored in that one minion and but
in 26000 dimension when minion just
disappears so if you have a long we need
a lot more to really we can do the
moment because everybody's in 26000
dimension nobody is close to anybody
else which is very far away so you do
this very average which is not visually
appealing so I think I start looking at
that problem again because I think there
might be a better way to combine things
with five layers there and so you have a
tremendous capacity to store a library
of the Flutie's yeah drawing problem
yeah and a lot of time I've actually
subconscious so we're kind of like a
camera taking everything in and I'm
always surprised sometime see something
and I never thought about because I
think people probably then study on I
don't know on top of my head but I think
people probably study that question like
what's from your memory recall I don't
know put a subject and then ask them to
recall an image of a bear and then do
your voxel analysis and see whether or
not you can reconstruct that image from
if a bear it's very vague you can try
that but if you don't buy anything it
doesn't mean that they couldn't do it
right because bear your past experience
come in
and then you put the images away yeah
that's more precise yeah well we need
money to use fMRI machine you just
nothing is participate it yeah but yeah
I think Oh awesome somebody might have
I'll be very surprised you haven't done
that yes for each person so in our
conscious brain we think about an image
in our mind and we imagine there's only
one one image in our mind at a time but
when you are thinking about something
and you get sidetracked you stop
thinking about something else there's
some moment when you have two things in
your head you actually like the neurons
have fired when you were thinking about
whatever your previously thinking about
and then some new Nine's new some new
neurons are patterning and that's a
synaptic response so this response is
receding as the other one is raising so
there is some sort of mixture model
happening I'm just wondering if if
you've considered this at all because
perhaps something you could be picking
up that adds noise is concurrent thought
I mean people say that our auditory
complex can only think of one language
at a time so like someone can't be
speaking to you and someone else and you
write something some people can do this
but there's a lot of work that shows you
only sort of have one processor but I
don't know for for a sort of
subconscious thought or just in our own
mind when we think about experiences or
images and we're trying to reflect that
in an image from the brain if we're
happy you could perhaps you can be
picking up two separate images firing
and especially as we're changing thought
or thinking about new things happening
it's a possibility we haven't dealt with
that I think there's a bigger problem is
actually attention sometimes you stare
at the screen actually you relate to
what you're saying thinking about
something else and there's some
attention tracker which we don't have an
experiment so I think that's a bigger
problem often it's just your mind went
off right you're looking at it but
you're really not seeing it so at the
before the attention definitely play a
role writing but I think what you were
saying that I felt like you need a lot
more precise measurement than we have to
be able to decouple yeah I think I don't
know if people are talking about 70 but
since it hasn't been
because you have this tree though I
haven't hear people using 17 machine
that's try to good it's just seems to be
hard to make it work it's very sensitive
so I think with more precise maybe
multimode measurements or something but
I think the data we have I think would
be very hard to be able to see in fact
that's just my guess but it's it's
definitely a lot of times maybe the
model doesn't work is because this
person just spaced out right they have
been there for two hours right who's
gonna even they fixated they are
actually graders you know it's like who
is gonna fix it for that long right
maybe difficult tired right actually we
can maybe see this things get worse or
something involving a badger experiment
data I think in theory we could do that
but for this data I think would be very
hard to find interesting idea okay so
let's think been again thank you
[Applause]